gérald darmanin le nouveau ministre de
l'intérieur à mérignac ce matin il a
remis la légion d'honneur à titre
posthume à mélanie de mai la gendarme
tué par un chauffeur s'est tué samedi
dernier il a salué je cite l'engagement
professionnel sans faille de l'agent des
forces de l'ordre une entrée en
fonctions qui reste difficile pour
l'ancien ministre de l'action et des
comptes publics on appelle il est accusé
de viol pour une affaire qui date de
2009 le ministre de l'intérieur s'est
d'ailleurs défendu chez nos confrères de
rtl c'était ce matin il a invoqué le
droit à la présomption d'innocence
je ne commente pas les affaires de
justice en général et pas la mienne
depuis trois ans en particulier
je constate simplement qu'il y ait eu
trois décisions de justice deux enquêtes
préliminaires ont été classées sans
suite et un non lieu rendu par deux
juges d'instruction
alors il me semble qu'au bout de trois
décisions de justice on peut penser que
j'ai le droit à la présomption
d'innocence